what a great segue now that we've
established the woke topic to talk about
what has been going on this week that
everybody is talking about dave
chappelle special the reaction netflix
and the trans community now if we
establish right here at the beginning
that all three of us are supporters of
all laws that protect trans people that
we believe in all the
dignity equality and respect that can be
afforded to trans people can we have an
honest free discussion about this many
people don't think so but right many
people that's what bothers me to begin
with that there is this is what i call
the one true opinion a very apropos of
your religion theme john
there is the one true opinion and there
isn't there isn't just one true opinion
i'm a free speech guy
now i'm team dave but that doesn't mean
i'm anti-trans
we can have two thoughts in our head at
the same time
am i right about that i hope
but there's only one truth
there's a certain kind of person
who and the book that i wrote i have to
mention it explicitly once it's called
woke racism the book that i
didn't i mentioned it yes you did i did
but i have to say it too okay
it's fantastic right thank you very much
but what a certain kind of person thinks
is that what we must hold front and
center is battling or striking battle
poses against power differentials and
that must center everything that we do
intellectually artistically morally that
is the main thing there might be some
other things you can barbecue now and
then but that is the center and if
you're not doing that you're not just
somebody who's annoying you're a moral
pervert and you must be defenestrated
and chased out of the public square they
don't put it in those words but
unfortunately that's what they mean
that's what we're up against and so
that's why there's some people who think
that there's one truth they think they
have found the final solution they think
they are kant
they aren't
[ __ ] the philosopher
see i dropped some people
want to confuse anybody out there and
get us in bigger trouble than we always
are
immanuel kant k-a-n-t he's a philosopher
and he was a
[Laughter]
[ __ ] going to lose my job no you're not
i'm going to lose mine well we're all
going to lose our job okay but as a
professor though
of language
here's what
i thought i would get you on even though
that's going to be the subject of my
editorial next week because
it's i think a much bigger subject than
just this but this gets at it words have
meaning
but not anymore and when i hear
transphobic phobic has a meaning
fear
i i'm not transphobic if i merely
disagree with you it's not hate i mean
here's what some one of the reactions
from someone who worked at netflix said
this is not an argument with two sides
well right away you lost me
it is an argument with trans people who
want to be alive and people who don't
want us to be well that's just
ridiculous
dave chappelle does not want you to not
be alive amen it's just
and
you know you're not automatically right
if you're trans
you're completely equal you're just not
automatically right and it doesn't
behoove everybody to
get their mind around
very new changes i mean
we were boy and girl for a very long
time
it was it's only been 10 years since how
long have we had gay marriage you know i
mean talking about the democratic voter
i'm sure there's a guy in
ohio going i just got on board with gay
marriage could you give me a minute
this idea that we're not
we're not any gender when we're born is
very new and very radical that you're
born it's just jump ball
but you have a penis it could mean
you're a boy but that's a you know i
mean that's a very new idea and
i'm not sure i'm down with all of it and
i don't have to be
but he dave wasn't battling power
differentials he wasn't immediately on
board and that person from ohio needs to
do some learning and some adjustments
yes but that means that you are a
heretic and you have to be pushed out a
window because you are not battling the
power differentials and what you see is
that this is there's one thing this is
these people people who do this about
race who do this about trans who do this
about anything think of themselves as a
head of the curve they think of
themselves as indicating some sort of
higher wisdom really it's a very simple
way of looking at things people like
this no matter what they're arguing on
the basis of are telling us the way you
would have thought of it when you were
five years old is the proper way to
think of it that doesn't work
never will
bill
you've been a comedian being a comedian
seems like a really really tough job
i think we can agree that comedian's
primary role is to entertain
and it's sometimes to make us think but
no one thinks it's a comedian's role to
tell us how to think or what to think
and attributing that role to dave or any
other comedian doesn't serve art the
artist or society at all
well
i mean i was going to read some of these
reviews i'm just going to read this one
from npr it's because the reviews from
the critics
so at variance with the audience rotten
tomatoes that that's a amalgam of
reviews i think in this case seven his
special got a 43 percent audience 95.
says a lot
about the differentiation between real
people and the we're seeing this again
and again defund the police says oh so
sophisticated person and a person living
in a dangerous neighborhood doesn't want
it and there are more of them than there
are of the people you know wearing
t-shirts saying defund the police or
latinx i don't have any problem with
latinx but it doesn't seem to be making
any inroads into the communities where
most latinx people live and so you have
this sort of educated dialect way of
thinking and that's the case here where
all of these people i think to get back
to this simplicity idea they see that
dave chappelle is a comedian they're
layers of wit and irony and attitude
going on and instead we're told to just
read it as if it was the three bears and
we're being told that that's
sophisticated when really that means
that these people who are you know so
annoyed that anybody says some words or
expresses some ideas are saying that
most of america aren't sophisticated and
yet last time i checked they were
arguing on the basis of disempowered
people or that there's a connection that
because you don't agree with what he
said which again i don't think is
transphobic a lot of the special is
about how he has this friendship with a
trans person who is his opening act
but that it's going to lead to violence
now there has been an uptick in violence
as there was with asian americans in the
last couple of years
of course we condemn this of course we
should do everything we can to stop it
but i don't think dave chappelle special
has anything to do with it no now let me
read the npr
npr said it sounds like chappelle is
using white privilege to excuse his
homophobia and transphobia wait now dave
chappelle can have white privilege i'm
really confused now
you